[Music]
talk about outer space hello I'm Jenny
slate and today we're going to talk
about Arno Penzias and Robert Wilson and
their beautiful cosmic discovery says my
dog's penis and then I've also had his
balls remove my balls you can't have
them I took them away but I have a full
vagina in 1960 Bell Labs made this like
giant listening device for NASA but then
by the time they were ready to use it a
better thing I've been built then it was
just like by itself all by itself in New
Jersey a lonely horn but two scientists
Arno Penzias and Robert Wilson they were
like oh whoa hold on hold on if no one's
using that could have use it they're
like come on down to the horn so they
get to the Warren they're like we are a
beautiful scientists with lovely minds
and we want to listen to the sounds
between the stars
boink they're like let's go babe let's
listen up oh god I love thinking of them
calling each other babe so they listen
and the sound is a hundred times louder
than any sound they expected to hear
right
the universe is like Oh find out about
me all so they're like what is this
darn sound it's coming from everywhere
in the sky at once everywhere everywhere
everywhere and then they're like no
there's no way a sound could come from
everywhere at once so we have to
eliminate all the other sounds that
might be like interfering so first they
thought maybe someone doesn't care about
science they're like it must be coming
from you know New York urban
interference you know New York is a city
with buildings and lights and people and
subway and blah blah blah so they're
like pointed they're pointed the horn in
New York City no that's not more we're
hearing forget about you New York maybe
it's coming from a military base nearby
and then there's like pointing up the
military bases but they can hear that
noise coming from there no it is int
maybe it's from the Sun they pointing at
the Sun and the Sun was like I'm just
the Sun I don't give a they're like
it's not the Sun what the funk is this
man and then they're like we should
check our device what if there's
something inside of this thing like you
know mold or the skeleton of a hobo that
crawls in there to get shelter they look
inside the horn guess what this skin
thing is filled with pigeons houston we
do have a problem and it's pigeons are
know is like you do it Robert you
kill them Roberts like
you do it guess what they did they shot
them with a gun a shotgun then they were
like well that'll do it mm-hmm after
they wiped the bird blood off of their
hands they're both like r.i.p these
pigeons let's do this
blink start to listen they're like ocean
they hear it again what the hunk is this
right now
they don't have the answer they don't
know what to do they listen through the
horn for years they're going through
their papers their papers their papers I
can't get it oh there's nothing here
woof
this one's boring oh this is in another
language it's being like we're never
gonna figure this out finally they find
a study done by a scientist whose name
is deke hmm he had this crackpot theory
that the universe instead of being
infinite actually started at some point
deke is like 13.8 billion years ago
aka oldest checker watch I think the
universe started with like okra the
explosion aka the Big Bang but they had
no way to prove it then these two guys
from New Jersey who've been listening to
this pigeons horn huh call him up
they're like we hear this thing it's
like have you ever heard of that before
he's like oh my god
that's it this is what we've been
studying cosmic microwave
what is that word what is the word we
know it what is it
cosmic microwave background radiation
okay it's the sound of microwaves from
the Big Bang and they're like yeah we
gotta be got it this is basically the
sound of the Big Bang they wanted to try
to find anything but what they found was
the sound of everything I had to
unfollow NASA on Instagram because it
made me too crazy it would just be like
this is a picture of black hole Penzias
and Wilson get the Nobel Prize for
Physics everyone flips out and they were
like yes the Big Bang is real it
happened it's real you guys did it
Penzias and and oh the other guy I just
keep thinking of Winslow but I know
that's Carl Carl Winslow discovered the
Big Bang Derrick what this is right here
this is the sound of the echo of the
universe being created
suck on that for a second see how you
like it just for a second the universe
is like
on the pin universe second at first
sight the year is 1963 Gordon Cooper
uses military test pilot from Oklahoma
NASA had just begun and so he was one of
seven astronauts chosen for the project
mercury also really chill he was like
please call me Gordo
don't call me Gordon I'm not that
official right and so all these space
missions go off without a hitch and
NASA's like we've done really low seem
fast NASA and they're patting themselves
in the back and Gordo's like guys I
totally get it like that's really cool
like Pat's on the back but if you want
to send a man to the moon you should
maybe see if someone could be in space
for I don't know 24 hours and NASA's
like uh yeah I guess
Gus yeah sure Gus Gordo oh sorry I'm an
idiot that's okay you're fun
so Gordo goes on the launch pad and has
to be like hey just like really quick
but don't touch anything now so it
completely control everything it was so
bad that the astronauts felt like spam
and a can is what they refer to
themselves as so anyway Louie launches
his face and it's like three two one
blast-off
is shooting that okay good
he gets up in his face and everything's
cool he's like I'm orbiting the Earth oh
I'm sorry I work you can swear no my mom
I tried I'm not a mentor I swear
so he's in space he sends back the first
TV images of a human back to earth he
has a little mu powdered roast beef
dinner he's just having a bowl so he
takes a nap the first guy to ever sleep
in space he wakes up and he's like it's
good to be Gordo and then he's like oh
no it's not because oh I have no
stabilization unit everyone on Mission
Control is freaking out they're like oh
god this doesn't look good and Gus
Grissom is like bro I love you I'm gonna
tell your wife you're hero
Gordo's like notes happen I'm gonna take
control over the spaceship Gus is like
you're about to do something none that
no one has ever done before
and Gordo's like yeah no I know so just
shut the up Gus and I've got
control and he starts to take over
manual control
but at that moment he loses radio signal
with Gus Grissom and so he gets a radio
signal over to his friend John Glenn
who's on the recovery boat over in Japan
and he's like John Glenn hey it's me
Gordo um I have absolutely no power in
my spacecraft and I just want to get
back home because I'm a really chill guy
it's me Gordo and he's like okay here's
we're gonna do and so together they go
through this checklist but put this
thing up like press this but and there's
all these things he needs to do but then
Gord is like oh there's carbon dioxide
meters going off and it's like you're
and he's like oh my god you're right
I'm totally but I know but he's chiller
than that no hold on he's way calmer
that jungle and look my carbon dioxide
meters going off and it's like a hundred
degrees and my Canon which means he's
dying but he's not being a Debbie Downer
about it he's like I need to get to
Earth but like manual reentry had never
been done before so if he enters Earth's
atmosphere too steep he's gonna blow up
so he says okay
there's the Big Dipper there's Little
Dipper Gemini he draws an axis on the
window and uses the constellations as
his constant and he says this is going
to be my aim at which I can enter
Earth's atmosphere which i think is
pretty incredible
so John Glenn is like okay ten nine
seven six quarters like let's just like
do it I'm ready so he fires what does
this mean what's it called when there's
fire coming out of stuff when when it's
like a fire he fires the Rockets he had
a $5 wristwatch and that's what he used
to figure out how long to fire his
Rockets Bordeaux is like oh and he
splashes down and he has the most
accurate splashdown every in NASA
history it's like so chill he's like hey
as I made a I'm not surprised it's me
Gordo big whoop
[Music]
Gordo changed the game great here's a $5
wristwatch to every not cosmonauts and
astronauts all the knots not hello I'm
Kyle Kinane and we're going to talk
about the first spacewalk 1965 space
race underway America it's Russia
so Russia they've been sending animals
Oh poo
but then the US they sent a monkey up
there and that Russia is just like who's
the most maniac Russian we have Pavel
Valley Evan Alexa Lea mouth so Russia
says Pavlov Alexei do you wanna do some
age stuff we'd like you to be the first
human beings to do a spacewalk evey a of
electorally
extra vehicular activity imagine what
it's like to build floating around in
the eighties except this is a sixties
they go what do you got going on with
your life nothing's in there yes yes
I'll do missions called the Bose God -
and so Russia's watching on TV
finally Russia's got something like
awesome good luck with your rock and
roll in your Beach Boys we got this
so launch when it pops off man launch
pops off it's good
they're like we did it where to warm it
Lina pressurize the suit leaves the
airlock I'm floating in space I'm
floating in space
hey the best thing ever there in my life
he's the first human being to do so
everybody's watching TV this guy's out
there the old countries oh we did it
we're the best
the first secretary Brezhnev was like
they didn't have good job doth she not
barfi don't worry don't worry
Selim it was like okay I did it
can I get back into this craft well I
can't even fit inside of it because a
suit blew up too big he's gonna fill
this fill the suits filled up he's stuck
he's like Oh tubs this whole thing so
they cut the feet they immediately cut
Mozart's Requiem which is some
depressing funeral jam I'm assuming
right now you'll play it right now it's
just some sad
but then Lina secretly realize he can
reel a can in front of nozzle the
depressurize temperature temperature
spikes he's almost got the bends nearly
kills himself just to get back inside to
the spacecraft
he then oh that shouldn't be the most of
it he's in and then they can't get the
hatch closed like not like like like
sitcom-style nothing's gonna go right
why am I looking at this one should I be
looking at anywhere else whether there's
one point of the couch so this so anyway
they takes a - great fine great but that
throws balance off of the whole goddamn
machine so they're stuck twirl it around
Julian have says to babble we gotta land
this right in now they're truck they're
trying to figure out the try not like
calculate the trajectory just get back
just land on Russian soil if we land we
land in China
that'll be up because of
something that wikipedia tells us they
twirl towards the Earth and then wait
whoa Oh caboose
will landed oh man we should get out of
this capsule Oh we'll get we gotta kick
it out we shake your eyes capsule we
should blow the doors how with these
tiny clusters were provided
oh good we're out oh where are we over
the tundra oh don't do that
don't it I know how TV works all right
they land 2,000 kilometers off their
mark in Siberia which is a real place
in the middle of mating season for
wolves and bears it's below zero
temperatures wolves bears all just bones
Jesus all I can say to each other's well
I guess we should start put some sweet
kisses what happened to them after yeah
Derek don't say nothing yeah I just want
to get what begins there in Siberia
there blessed and flares up their food
we're sprites and then after 30 hours
they're fine
finally they got rescued
[Music]
oh they're just some lunatics that say
yes to an experiment cosmonauts
astronauts did yes yes said why not what
a button what a button in 1916 an
American hands up and every America is
like oh my god that on the moon it's
amazing and shows like hold up
that's all white dudes what the right so
she gives this big speech and she's like
NASA get your together
can you please recruit someone to be an
astronaut who's not a white dude and
NASA's like okay cool but like can you
do it cuz we don't know anybody who's
got a white dude so Nichelle Nichols was
like uh like ladies have to do
everything she travels around the
country and she recruits people to be in
NASA and she's like hey by people Asians
lady people join go space and they're
like pickle and she recruited Sally
right and then she recruits Colonel
Buford he's the first black dude to be
at NASA and
she recruited in a Jemison and she's
like hey you should apply for NASA and
may Jemison is like oh my god you were
on Star Trek I love you but she's like
pay attention so Nichelle Nichols was
like the first black lady to go to space
for fake and she recruited the first
black lady to go to space for real
she literally integrated space everybody
who's really good at math or whatever
you have to be good at to be go to NASA
can do whatever they want to do but we
still need to prosper if we're gonna
live long yeah this America right now
it's trying so hard
you